- wait we will have a specific time
allocated for QA so you will see a
screen that says questions and during
that time if you can have your questions
ready I'd be happy to answer any of
those I'll try and not pause in the
middle of something to address any
questions but hopefully we'll get
through this in the future if you have
any questions or you would like us to
address a specific topic or an issue
instead of the topic popping up during
the session it would be great if you
could add it to the forum I'll do a
little review of where the different
elements of the program are today and
once you find that forum you'll be able
to post your questions or issues that we
need to address and then I'll dedicate
time in the beginning of the session
each time to make sure that that issue
is addressed so today we have our
session - this is the last session that
it's going to be open to anyone who
would like to explore this program the
session is focused on multiple sequence
alignment so we'll talk about how
comparison of sequences could be done
using a computational method called
multiple sequence alignment or MSA what
MSA does is identify how to best align
sequences and find a consensus sequence
so where do they all agree and what is
the best the best consensus between
multiple genomes and also what is the
quality so how do we evaluate the
quality of that consensus and then using
that alignment how can we identify
relationships between groups of
sequences so Before we jump into our
session I'll just give a brief overview
the program that we're in right now is
called bioinformatics for infectious
diseases when we speak about the
application of bioinformatics to study
pathogens and their interaction with the
human body and we will talk about
different aspects of bioinformatics
methods using several curated data sets
from coronaviruses Ebola virus Rhino
virus tuberculosis and others and
the program is actually divided into two
different parts the first part is more
educational more theoretical where we
talk about different methods we kind of
design a pipeline and run it and discuss
outputs we start thinking about
questions that are appropriate to ask
from different types of datasets and how
to get a conclusive answer and what is
that entail in terms of both statistical
significance and biological
interpretation and then the second part
of the program is more practical and
more open-ended and designed to allow
you to develop a project of your own so
in the second part of the program that
will start in June we will actually
provide you with tools and support to
design and analyze a project of your own
make sure that you get it to an
interpretable result and then give you
an opportunity to present your project
and we can discuss how that project
compares to other publications and
projects out there so that you get some
feedback on what you've done so that's
the program that we're talking about
right now it started on May 4th but this
is only the second session so anyone can
still join this week now to participate
in the rest of the program in the
program in the first part of the program
we will have several educational
sessions like today where we'll talk
about different elements of viral and
bacterial biology we'll talk about ozone
artic spillover I will talk about
vectors and hosts viral evolution
replication bacterial infections we'll
talk about how to analyze data from
viral genomes and next-generation
sequencing data and what types of
comparisons and analyses we can do with
some of the tools that we will discuss
in the context of this program and we
also prepared a number of curated
datasets that are organized in a way
that they show how to go from general or
exploratory analysis to
developing a hypothesis and then
eventually developing a full analysis
with a biological interpretation in mind
and those curated data sets we hope will
either provide you a context for a
project that you will design on your own
so essentially you can pick one of these
curated data sets and take the analysis
into your own direction or provide you
with a template that you can apply to
any other type of a viral or bacterial
project that you would like to try and
work on for the second part of this
program so in the context of the program
we will provide you with tools and
support for how to use those tools as
well as some educational materials that
are available for a synchronous learning
so in other words you will be able to
learn about the things that you don't
know using these online materials we
hope that in sessions like today we can
go through the material in a way that it
helps us identify which areas are
unclear which topics need to be covered
in a more comprehensive way and we can
either point you to the right direction
using research articles or some of the
tutorial style materials that we've
prepared that combine some theoretical
as well as practical exercises and go
through the steps with a lot of
explanation so the program we have a
group of members that join a program and
this program is hosted on our
educational portal so this educational
portal provides us with specific tools
that help guide every participant to get
to a place where they're more
independent and familiar with the tools
and the datasets and the projects and
are able to conduct the analysis in an
effective way and in fact we use some of
these tools I'll show here in a few
minutes how we use those tools to
interact with the participants in
between sessions making sure that
everybody stays on
the same page and is able to continue
without getting lost as we go through a
lot of these different topics so let me
briefly show you what I'm talking about
this is the link I'm going to put it in
chat for all of you that are already
participants you should be able to thank
you picture you should be able to find
that fairly easily and then those of you
that are not yet participants you will
be able to see what it looks like once
you join so this is the page you will
see here a few different tabs for home
forum courses project progress
assignments and then here you can open a
little more and see here a few other
menu items not all of them are going to
be visible for you if you're not logged
in so the first thing that you need to
do is register on this portal and make
sure that you have a completed profile
completed profile is important not just
because we want to see your picture and
we want to know what's your name it's
also important if you want to use the
certificates that you get at the end of
the program they're generated
automatically and they actually use your
name so if your name is something that
you know is not going to look like you
know cool boy 1 2 3 right that's what's
going to appear on your certificate so
make sure that you're updating your
profiles as you join the program now as
I mentioned we have a forum and on this
forum we interact around specific topics
so for example we post your previous
recordings and you can see that beeps I
already started posting our previous
recordings from the session that we had
last week and that we had this week on
Monday so if you want to see those you
can go in here and you'll be able to see
the links on YouTube and if you have any
questions about those specific sessions
you can post them here as well we all
get notifications all right we all get
notifications
about your questions
also I opened a topic in the forum for
specific questions so right now there
may be not many questions as everybody
is just getting oriented but as you have
specific questions maybe a pipeline
doesn't work or some other issue that
comes up please post it right here and
so I'll have enough time to prepare for
the next session and make sure that we
have everything ready here we also have
session data files and presentations so
starting from this session we started
posting here a PDF of the slides so a
lot of you requested the slides from
last session we will post that here as
well but for this session if you would
like to have the presentation and the
PDF of the presentation and the data
files that we will use today so all of
that is organized right here okay the
other thing that we talked about is that
we actually monitor activity of the
group that is participating in the
course and we try to understand that
you're doing the right thing so I just
want to point out how that happens so
here you can see the different
participants of the program and the
different activities for example
somebody ran a pipeline or somebody
completed a course so so we discussed
the outputs and the issues that we see
for example someone might run a pipeline
that really isn't going to produce the
next type of output that they're
expecting and so we will you know
discuss those issues as they are being
worked on so these are the educational
kind of features that we've designed
into this program that help us make sure
that we understand where the issues are
and address them in a timely way so
let's take a look at an overview of
where everybody is this is just for
those that have already registered and
have completed their profiles you will
see a general overview
of this group in terms of the progress
and by the progress mean we mean
practical activities running pipelines
as well as completing coursework so you
see that we met the first time on May
4th and we discussed next-generation
sequencing what types of sequencing
methods there are and and how those are
applied to sequence viral genomes and
host transcriptomes and then today we
are talking about multiple sequence
alignment and phylogenetic relationship
so you can see those updated on this
chart and these two graphs show us the
activity of the whole group in terms of
completing online materials as well as
running pipelines so the gray is the
pipeline's and the yellow are the
educational activities and here you can
see some of the participants and what
they are working on in terms of
practical or educational components of
the program so this is just a good
overview of where we are as a group
okay so we talked about the forum we
talked about the sessions if any of you
want to see previous sessions you can go
to the forum and check those out beep so
maybe you can post a link to the forum
just so that everyone can find it we
also talked about the progress and
today's session and so now let's review
what we did in our last session so I saw
some of you tried to replicate some of
the pipelines that we did and maybe had
some challenges and so let's just make
sure that all of that is clear so last
session we talked about next generation
sequencing next generation sequencing
refers to the second generation
sequencers like Illumina sequencers the
second generation the first generation
sequencers were the Sanger sequencers
and these are the second generation and
of course to generalize that we can call
that next generation and the difference
between the first generation the second
generation is that the second generation
is called shotgun sequencing it
sequences random pieces from a
collection of shared material DNA or RNA
material and produces short reads and
one of the bigger challenges and then
understanding where those reads map to
on the reference genome is called
alignment or mapping and so last time we
talked about how we can take a sequence
read archive z-- that collect an archive
of reads of short reads and map them
onto a database of different available
genomic sequences from viruses bacteria
and other organisms and then also map
the reads that we identify belonging to
a specific organism on the reference
genome of that organism so what you see
here are some of those reads aligned to
the reference genome of Ebola virus we
talked about different approaches to
metagenomic and viral sequences
so we talked about how we can design
specific primers to identify a virus a
or a group of viruses like a species and
those will be designed specifically for
a conserved region or a gene for example
the we took a implication of the Ebola
virus a specific gene that can help us
identify presence of Ebola virus in
fecal samples from bats there are other
approaches as well for example we can do
no amplification and just do total DNA
or RNA a good example that we started
talking about last time is a project
that is available for everyone called
spot up Tara from Des Peres which is a
cell line that uses a back a plant cell
line to produce different biologics so
vaccines and proteins that we use so
there we saw how you can sequence the
expression gene expression data from
that spot of Terrafugia panda and then
take the not mapped reads and then align
them to again the same database and
identify presence of very specific
contaminants and then also there's
what's called environment so microbiome
at a genomic sequencing that is actually
designed to help us identify the
adversity in a given environmental
sample environmental could mean taken
directly from the gut or taken from
feces or taken from water or taken from
soil and so what we can see there is
really trying to look at hypervariable
regions regions that all come from for
example a bacterial 16s ribosomal RNA
and help us understand diversity and
characterize the community of different
bacteria
so we talked about those three types of
sequences sequencing methods we also ran
a pipeline like I mentioned and so I
just want to make sure that we all
understand what that pipeline was and
what was it supposed to produce as I was
seeing what people were running not
everyone got it right the first time so
just to remind everyone what it was that
we actually did so what we did was we
took a an sra file a sequence read
archive so this is the name of the
archive srr 107 6 9 5 0 0 which is a
metagenomic amplicon of Ebola virus but
specific to a bat feces sample and so
that file looks like this so you can see
the sequence read archive name right
here and you can see those short reads
their sequence as well as the quality of
that read so we took this file it's a
pretty big file hundreds of megabytes
megabytes and then we uploaded that file
and used it to map on the virus genome
so we have a database from viruses of
different viral genomes from NCBI and we
just used bowtie to the line which is a
method of alignment of those reads onto
that database and then we also created
an abundance table and that is the
script that allows us to calculate how
many reads fall onto one of those
genomic elements so as we did that we
had an output one of the outputs was a
table and that table showed us that we
have multiple different accession
numbers and those accession numbers
contain if we look them up on NCBI one
of them would be Ebola
so there's influenza there's other
phages bacteriophages
but we were interested in Ebola and so
then we ran a second pipeline and that
second pipeline took the
Reed's that we identified that fall on
to that reference genome and we actually
produced a visualization and that
visualization looked like this where we
saw that there are Reed's that align in
a certain position on this Ebola virus
genome and that is kind of where we
ended right so we saw the reeds how they
align we talked about coverage and then
you probably noticed that some positions
were different from the reference genome
so for example here at see here it's T
right so those are the difference and
and this is what we are going to be
talking about today so today we're
actually going to be talking about how
do we go to the next step and understand
what are the differences in the
sequences that we are finding okay and
here's just a description of how that
protocol for amplification of different
types of viruses it's actually not
designed specifically for Ebola was
designed for 16 different viruses
including influenza Ebola and other
viruses and so that's why you see here
others present as well okay so before we
go on to today's session I want to make
sure that we have addressed any of the
questions that you had about sequencing
techniques and how the first step of
once I generated some sequences how do I
know what sequences these are so if you
have any questions again put them into
chat and let's talk about multiple
sequence alignment next
okay so there are no questions let's
start talking about multiple sequence
alignment so multiple sequence alignment
will deal with variation in sequences
and so the variation in sequences as you
can see displayed right here has to do
with changes in one sequence compared to
another so we are not going to deal as
much with how different reads map and
where they map but more how different
individual nucleotides vary between
different sequences so where these
changes come from we are talking about
viruses right now so what we are talking
biologically is taking samples from
cells and looking at the presence of
different species that we can observe in
a sample or the different variations
variants of a virus so for example when
a number of viruses enter an organism or
attempt to enter enter an organism only
one of those might be successful so
again there are many many viruses in our
bodies at a given moment in time those
viruses the majority of those viruses
are actually helpful if not harmful
they're helpful because the majority of
the viruses affect bacteria and we need
some balance between bacteria in our
intestines for example and in different
places of our bodies and so viruses are
actually a part of that ecosystem but
some viruses are able to enter
sells and so when they enter into the
cells their goal is to go through the
steps of viral replication imitating a
sequence that would be native to the
cell so they are imitating and trying to
get the cell to incorporate that into
its assembly line and that assembly line
will help produce proteins that then
replicate other elements of the viral
sequence of the viral genome and put
together a whole theory on that then
eventually will be will be expelled from
the cell and oftentimes the cell will
die because the cell dies that causes
inflammation and immune response and so
there are many different areas in this
process that are pressures on the virus
right so the virus protects what's
inside protects the genome typically
that genome is either a DNA or an RNA
it's inside a very on and once it's
inside the virion
nothing happens it's static but once it
gets out of the virion
during the process of replication
different changes start happening to
that to that sequence for example the
reading of the sequence to produce
different elements and reproduce and
other copies of the same genome are
going to cause different changes
sometimes when this community of viruses
is expelled only specific variants will
remain intact to infect other cells and
so that process of going between tissues
entering into the cell replication all
of those cause different mutations or
changes to that genome so as a result we
have a community of different viral
organisms or viral genomes and have
accumulate they accumulate mutations in
their genomes so how can we study that
community we can study that community
by studying those changes in the genome
that is a process of viral adaptation
and we know that it has a specific
mutation rate it's actually a remarkable
capacity of these viruses to adapt to
new hosts so for example we talked about
viruses going between bats and humans or
non-human primates non-human primates
right monkeys and those changes are
occurring because of accumulation of
mutations in key regions of the viral
genome and so the rates of spontaneous
mutation vary between different viruses
RNA viruses for example mutate faster
than DNA viruses single-stranded viruses
mutate faster than double strand black
versus and genome size appears to
correlate negatively with mutation rate
so the longer the genome the last
mutation rate viral mutation rates are
modulated at different levels including
polymerase fidelity sequence context
template secondary structure cellular
microenvironments or where exactly do
they replicate in the cell replication
mechanisms proofreading some viruses
have a proofreading mechanism to correct
any big changes and access to host
replicas to repair and massive numbers
of mutations can be introduced by some
virus and coded diversity generated
elements as well as by host encoded
cited i'm alan i DM analysis so the cell
has specific ways to make sure that
deleterious mutations occur in the viral
genome they make sure that when they
identify this to be a non human for
example genome there are specific
mechanisms to intervene there and of
course the virus has to evade all of
these different responses and so this is
a process of virus host circuitry that
exchange different responses and
different mutations as a result we
observe
how these sequences change over time and
this is a response to this ongoing
process now as we talked about different
viruses have different genomes and
different structures so for example here
you can see mutations per site per year
this is the number of mutations per site
per year and this is the genome size so
here you can see single-stranded DNA
viruses double strand DNA viruses RNA
viruses are right here bacterial
eukaryotes etc and so we are way down
there because mutations are actually a
natural process including for mammals as
well so to study how these different
mutations characterize different strains
of viruses even within one species for
example the Ebola virus what we want to
do is to identify how the present-day
observed sequences of genomes could be
explained by phylogeny in other words
how did they originate from a common
ancestor so what we have is the concept
of evolutionary time on the x axis and
we have similarity on the y axis and so
what we are trying to combine is a way
to represent some kind of an
organizational structure taxonomic
structure between the different species
that we have occurring now and suspected
origins that we know should have existed
in the past
now there are many different visual
formats to actually visualize
phylogenetic trees this is a
phylogenetic tree this is a phylogenetic
tree and this is a phylogenetic tree so
they all show the same thing and what
we'll talk about today is how to
generate a phylogenetic tree based on
multiple sequence alignment and then how
to visualize it and what do we see when
we visualize that kind of a tree to do
that we will use a project that we
already started working on Ebola that
has very specific mutations that were
identified in the context of the 2014 to
2016 epidemic and this is based on a
publication the revolute the evolution
of Ebola by first insights from the
2013-2016 epidemic that was published in
nature review in 2016 so what happened
with this outbreak Ebola virus was first
detected in the 1980s so the human
sequence of the Ebola virus was detected
back then back then it was sampled from
Gabon ends a year and eventually so you
can see here this is a map from National
Geographic you can see in 1976 there
were 318 cases and 284 cases in Sudan
and the first outbreak was in 1976 in
Sudan ins a year and in Gabon there were
some outbreaks as well but this novel
outbreak in 2013 2016 happened right
here in this region of West Africa in
Guinea Sierra Leone and Liberia and you
can see here how their different kind of
epicenters for this outbreak the
suspected source for this outbreak again
was aa nautic spillover in other words
the virus came from some kind of a bad
perhaps - primate and then eventually to
a human so Ebola virus is the causative
agent of Ebola hemorrhagic fever EHS a
disease that affects humans and other
primates as well and the incubation
period for EHF is 2 to 21 days and
typical early symptoms include fever
chills and other symptoms that have
multi-organ that cause multi organ
stress and subsequent failure so in
other words the organs just start
stopped working and and blood starts
coming out of everywhere there's very
high death rate as high as 90% and worse
yet it is highly can
spreading through direct contact with
infected body fluids or skin or mucous
membrane contact and so this is
something that has been a big concern
for international organizations of
course to contain this disease in a
small you know numbers of people and
location but in 2014 the epidemic in
West Africa of course was a big deal and
but as a result of that we had the
opportunity to study Ebola virus and
understand how Ebola virus goes between
different hosts goes between different
you know hosts like bats apes and humans
and also understand how it spreads
what is the epidemiological aspect of
Ebola virus so that's what we'll talk a
little bit about today
Ebola virus is also related to other
similar viruses like the Marburg virus
and is the member of the family Philo
Verde and it's named for they for their
filamentous shape so this is what it
looks like kind of like a warm and it's
an enveloped non-segmented negative
stranded RNA virus Ebola virus particles
have at their core a viral nucleo capsid
which is these green things nuclear
protein nucleo capsid composed of a
helical single-stranded RNA genome
wrapped around viral protease NP VP 35
VP 30 and L the nucleo capsid is
surrounded by an outer viral envelope
studded with a viral glycoprotein spikes
GP so we'll talk about glycoproteins in
in the context of other viruses as well
and viral proteins vp40 and vp 24 said
between the nuclear capsid and the
envelope the viral cycle begins with how
cell entry through a poorly understood
mechanism once inside the viral RNA
dependent RNA polymerase binds to the
approximately 18 to 19,000 kilobase
genome as a complex with other factors
entrance
time's the negative strand genome into a
positive strand mm RNA so the goal of
this virus is to imitate like we said a
what happens naturally in the cell and
so it tries to show the cell this
negative strand RNA so that the cell
will think that it's an mRNA ready for
production so it makes it positive
strand mRNA and the seven so what's
important to understand is that this
whole genome has a specific
organizational structure for these
different proteins that you see here so
what do we see right here and we have a
question here how to make a phylogeny
with molecular clock and so let's talk
about what we see on this side so here
we see different strains identified of
Ebola virus this is again the accession
number we started talking about
accession numbers last time here you can
see where they were taken from so Gabon
caught the war Gabon and quick you could
do which is actually somewhere on the
border between Congo and Gabon and
Liberia so what we are seeing are
different strains and the dates where
they were when they were sampled and
this is the 2014 so one of the first
sequences that were actually taken
during that outbreak from 2013 to the
2014 16 story is the red line the
reference strain no this is actually
that new sequence that caused that
epidemic in 2013 2016 right so the
question was one of the original
questions would be where did this
originate from and how is it different
from previously known and studied
viruses right so we know a lot about
these that occurred in 1970s and 99
jeez and to that and early-2000s how can
we know what is different about this one
so that might give us insight into how
it will replicate how it will spread up
in the population okay so how do we then
interpret this phylogenetic tree so the
phylogenetic tree as we said seeks to
show us distance in terms of
evolutionary time and Link that
evolutionary time to real time since we
know real time of sample collection how
do we understand how they are related
and so if they were related if they were
closely related we would see that this
specific species would be somehow
connected into one of these other known
strains right and then it would give us
a better understanding of whether it's
something completely novel or something
that we already dealt with before how do
we do this kind of analysis okay that's
the next question how do we make these
kinds of trees how do we align those
sequences how do we actually study this
kind of data let's talk about that so
the first step is to do an alignment
right so alignment is a fairly simple
task it does not require any kind of
complex software in fact I will show you
today how you can do it in a matter of
minutes all of us together on NCBI so
freely used software you don't need
anything else
based on assembled genomes to do that
let's go to NCBI virus and select a
certain number of sequences again just
before I switch over to NCBI I'm going
to give you those specific sequences
that we would like to select okay and
these are going to be accession numbers
okay so let's go to
see I virus together and we will do this
together and for those of you that would
like to just get to the page that's
already prepared and not go through the
steps together with me I am going to
just also paste here in chats
I'm going to pay a stanch at this link
so that anyone can just directly go to
that page okay maybe keep it open okay
so let's go to NCBI a virus NCBI virus
sorry - right here so NCBI virus to get
there you just go yes if you want to
follow along please follow along that
will give you some you know independent
practice and you next time by the way we
have a whole section dedicated to
running pipelines together so we will
actually do a very detailed review of
today's and run some pipelines that are
meaningful okay so search by virus here
we can go to Ebola
okay you can see bola virus come up
right here and now we have 3,000 over
3,000 different nucleotide sequences of
course there's a lot of different things
here not all the hosts are interesting
to us so what do we want to do we're
actually going to filter this by
accession so what I'm going to do is
take that list of accession numbers I'm
going to paste them here and I will find
those accession numbers right here so
there's a total of nine different
sequences where they from there are some
from Liberia three from Liberia three
from Gabon and three from United Kingdom
okay why are we selecting these specific
ones all of them are from human but the
reason is because we have an older
series of sequences the original ones
from Gabon from 1996 that original but
somewhat old 1996 and then a couple or
six between the different locations
they're essentially the same time so all
of them were 2014-2015 but some are in
Africa and some are in Great Britain in
the UK okay so we selected them just to
kind of get a sense of the logic right
we are looking here at different genomic
sequences if
I click on this accession I will
actually be able to go there and see
what that accession looks like so I have
here all of the sequences in amino acids
these are amino acid sequences of
independent independent genes for
different proteins and then if I go to
the bottom I have the nucleotide
sequence in TCGA right for the full
genome and you can see that the full
genome is just under 19 thousand
nucleotides long ok so what we'll do
first to understand how multiple
sequence alignment is I'm just going to
select all of these all of these 9 and
I'm going to align them so just click
here on a line you'll have to wait just
a couple of minutes before the alignment
is done so as I said it's not a very
complicated task but here you can see
the alignment okay maybe it's not a very
comfortable way to view the alignment
but it kind of makes sense right what
are we seeing here we see here some kind
of a reference or a consensus and we see
the individual sequences right here and
what you see in red if you go to
coloring you will see that we are
looking at show differences and we can
look at frequency based differences okay
so even ncbi has some issues but what we
can see are some differences right so
differences between them so what do we
see here we see three sequences that
have a lot of differences and then we
see the rest that only have some
references or some differences right so
why are they so different right so the
answer might seem obvious the answer is
probably because if we hover over here
and we see what sequence this is okay
for some reason it's not showing
everything but we can see that this is
liberia again this is going to be
liberia so all of these you can go
through them all of these
top ones are the novel the new ones the
2014 and these bottom ones are the ones
from 1996 right so we can see just based
on changes in the nucleotide sequence
that there are changes a lot of changes
between these three and the other six
okay but how do we now visualize their
relationship how are they related to
each other so the other option that we
can do is to go back here and instead of
alignment build the phylogenetic tree so
we're going to click here and again
fairly quickly it is going to show us
those relationships that were interested
in so for example here you can see
United Kingdom Liberia United Kingdom
United Kingdom Liberia Liberia so all of
these are the 2014 and 15 by the way the
15 stands out and these are all the
2014's and here on the bottom you have
the 1996 okay so this is this shows us
this phylogenetic tree shows us whether
they came from some kind of a common
origin so indeed they did at some point
but realistically they're very different
right so these are these probably came
from a common origin a long time ago
here we don't see how long ago but a
long time ago and here they're really
not interrelated okay
so this is just a very quick overview of
what you can do to understand some of
these sequences now we can download
these sequences so here I download it
and we can look at a more detailed
characteristic of each sequence and what
we'll see is that some of them have been
directly sequenced from the wild type
for example from a patient sample from
their blood some of them have been
tissue cultured so in other words they
were taken from the blood and put into a
tissue culture to amplify generate more
virus and then they were sequenced and
they come from different
country collected in different year and
they belong to different strains and
those different strains are you know
visibly different here as well and then
we this is how we will group them in our
further analysis okay so what are some
additional considerations to the simple
analysis that we quickly did on NCBI
well we have to think about what do
these nucleobases nucleotides represent
so again like we said the virus is
trying to get into the human cell and
imitate what happens inside the human
cells so what happens inside the human
cell inside the human cell the cell has
the DNA and the DNA is organized into a
double strand of these different
nucleotides connected together into what
we call base pairs and tri codon so the
codons are trying nucleotide sequences
that form different types of amino acids
right and that's what this structure
actually defines what these different
genes encode for right so these genes in
the DNA are whenever the cell wants to
produce a certain protein it opens up
the double strand in a specific position
of the gene start transcribes that into
mRNA so it produces a complimentary mRNA
to the DNA and then translates that
sequence of mRNA into protein and
protein is made up of amino acids that
fold in a very specific way so to
understand how this virus changes and
what are the different changes that
characterize what we just saw that
relationship we need to understand the
impact of those substitutions deletions
or insertions by what do they represent
from a protein standpoint
so to understand that let's think about
the different types of point mutations
so different types of point mutations
could be of three different kinds they
could be substitutions where one letter
is substituted by another insertion when
a letter is inserted as that process
happens or deleted and so as a result
we'll have different types of
consequences to those different changes
what are those consequences we have
essentially four different types of
mutations so one of them is sense in
other words it doesn't change anything
right
it just substitutes one letter for
another without changing the amino acid
and that is what we call a neutral
mutation that mutation doesn't change
anything in terms of what it represents
but then there are three types that
actually do make a big change a missense
mutation a nonsense mutation and a
frameshift mutation so a missense
mutation is where there is a change in
the amino acid right and so the the
change is also important some amino
acids have different physical chemical
properties and so the bigger that change
from one property to another property
the bigger the impact on the protein
that it produces nonsense mutations they
create a stop codon that terminates
translation right so in other words you
can get a shorter sequence so just by
changing specific nucleotides you will
get a very different protein that might
have a very different function and then
you have frameshift mutations those can
be from addition or removal of
additional bases and so you can have a
sequence that is completely different
from the original protein right so this
is important to keep in mind so whenever
we do this analysis whenever we do this
for linemen what we saw on NCBI is very
basic
it just shows us changes at the
nucleotide level and relationship based
on frequency
of occurring nucleotide changes but here
we want to actually look in a greater
detail and understand the impact of the
different changes and then to understand
how from an evolutionary standpoint
those might might actually take place
and the impact that that will have on
the viral sequence so what we have to do
is to make sure that we convert the
nucleotide sequence by using codon
mapping and understand the amino acid
that is produced from these try
nucleotide codons and we have a specific
chart that we can follow that is known
from the different changes in the
different positions of those codons that
make a specific change so we will now do
a similar analysis but in a much greater
detail so what we'll do is we'll take
the nucleotide sequence we'll convert it
to an amino acid sequence alignment and
as a result we'll be able to incorporate
some evolutionary analysis into the
phylogenetic tree to understand an
evolutionary distance okay so let's do
that together this is what we'll do
we'll take those same nine different
sequences that we already looked at
those came from Liberia Gabon and Great
Britain and we will create a simple
pipeline
do these steps so we'll do multiple
sequence alignment based on nucleotide
sequences then convert them to him amino
acid and then also look at codon changes
which position in the code on the change
occurred to understand how evolutionary
difficult or simple that change should
be right and then we will create a
phylogenetic tree based on a model and
so I'll talk a little bit about the
different types of evolutionary analyses
to build that phylogenetic tree to do
that
beep chair was posted some of the files
that we'll use to do that so please find
that link either on the forum or maybe
beeps you can post it here again for
anyone that wants to download and of
course this is going to be using the T
bio info platform where you have already
probably been able to visit and play
around with
okay and after this we'll have some time
for questions so let's quickly do this
before our session is over we will go to
areas of analysis okay so this is our
server platform and and again your
pipelines are monitored their so we can
help you if you have any questions and
see what went wrong so please navigate
to server to - bio info and here we will
use phylogenetic tree so this section
right here for those of you that don't
have access perhaps you only have access
to a demo account you can also use the
demo so there's a demo right here that
you can follow along with but those of
you that are participants of the program
you can join here and we'll actually do
the analysis together okay so these are
going to be FASTA files right so we're
not using fast queue files right now
when using FASTA files click right here
right here we want to upload some of
those files so we'll just click on add
files and this is the data that beeps
are shared with us and here we
essentially have three different FASTA
files so those three different sequences
for each type for each group are inside
right so here we have Ebola three files
from UK three files from Liberia three
files from Gabon so what we want to do
is just select all three of them and
upload okay then we want to organize
them into groups so we'll create three
different groups and put UK Liberia and
Gabon okay we could have done this by
downloading just individual faster files
and you know then organizing them here
as well
okay then we want to have the we want to
have some kind of an out-group
reference right in other words we want
to have some file that is very specific
to a sampling date right because we want
to associate this with real time
so we're going to adhere if you read the
directions upload one GenBank file for
framing code on so we want to have a GB
or a GenBank file which is the original
sequence of Ebola from was a year from
1997 right because we have a sample here
from Gabon from 1996 okay then we have
two files GenBank or FASTA so that we
can estimate evolutionary time so that
it understands what the evolution looks
like okay and so we have those here from
Gabon 2002 and Liberia 2014 okay so we
add these files here this will establish
the evolutionary time and now we're
ready to start so we start here we want
to do multiple sequence alignment just
like what we did right based on
nucleotide sequence then we convert that
sequence to amino acids and you can see
that there are different charges to the
amino acid so we'll incorporate that
into our alignment and the MSA position
right so this is specific codon
positions for further phylogenetic
analysis this is something that is based
on a publication I encourage all of you
to look at this publication to
understand how the different codon
positions have an impact on the
evolution so here we can select codon
third position and for Dean for example
that's true okay this will take a little
bit longer if we select it as false and
we'll take a little bit faster and now
we have a choice of different types of
phylogenetic trees so there are
different models essentially a
phylogenetic tree is a mathematical
model that accounts for the evolutionary
process and tries to match it with the
data that it has available now these
processes are typically done using
Markov chain models and this is a
statistical approach that estimates how
likely a change is to occur so there are
three different options that we have for
beast beast stands for this kind of
Bayesian analysis that we are doing and
those are coalescent you'll process and
birth-death process so the most
appropriate for this type of analysis is
the birth-death process which is a model
that kind of looks at both the birth so
new replication of new viruses and death
right so some viruses die some viruses
are born and so here we're going to have
the this model and we can select whether
we want to use amino acid or nucleotide
sequence so we can keep it nucleotide
let's click on save and click on end and
now all of you that have the option to
run the spy plan
please remember to name your pipeline
some kind of a way that we understand
what's happening for example I can say
Ebola virus Gabon Liberia and UK sorry
let's try to not use confidence here
okay and we'll do multiple sequence
alignment for large any beast okay and
run this pipeline now I already ran this
pipeline does not take a very long time
but I did run it so I want to show you
what the outputs look like okay so here
we want to look at a number of different
outputs and you can see that as you dig
deeper into the details you'll realize
how important these different settings
are and how insufficient it is to just
use straight out-of-the-box tools that
you don't know anything about how they
works
and sorry yes I will take a pause we
don't have that much time so what I want
to do is go through these different
steps and cover a few more slides so
that we are more ready to actually
practice this next time when we have a
full session dedicated to just running
the pipeline okay Claudia so I'm going
to try and complete the presentation
today so that next time we can do a
review and do a more slower step-by-step
process because as you will see our next
session is dedicated to selecting the
files and actually running the pipeline
you
okay so what we have here are different
outputs in different formats so you can
see a format called trees we have a
format in FASTA format we have PDF files
so let's open this PDF file and let's
see what's inside
okay so what's inside is that
phylogenetic tree that has the out-group
that has the reference genome and has
the groups of samples that we have
uploaded so the first question that we
might ask is are the groups in different
positions right so just like we saw on
NCBI we saw that group two and three so
for us group two and three were UK and
Liberia in 2014 and 2015 and group one
was the original and Gabon sequence so
here we see those three sequences so
this shows us that this is done
correctly in other words we see that
they are not related directly to each
other they're fairly distant but the
ones that are more closely related 2014
2015 you can see that the time
evolutionary time is much shorter right
compared to these now the rest of the
story is in the details right so here we
have the annotation based on the
different different annotation that we
prepared and that annotation by the way
is available in the data files if you
look on the Dropbox link and the goal of
our next few slides that I'll try and go
through fairly quickly is we don't have
that much time is to understand the
intricacies of this analysis and what
else we can learn from here ok so
another important file that I would
encourage you to look at is this one
full table dot TSV
which actually will show us how the
different sequences are aligned at the
amino acid level and the nucleotide
level okay so what we wanted to
understand right is the relationship
between them based on multiple sequence
alignment so this is a very primitive
multiple sequence alignment we see here
what the accession numbers are right so
each one of these represents an
accession number and those are the
different the different sequences that
we uploaded right so based on these
sequences we can for example see
nucleotide sequence in the beginning and
then down here below if you scroll down
you will start seeing the amino acid
sequence okay that starts from around
here so you can see how the changes at
the nucleotide level affect the changes
at the amino acid level and because it's
an excel now it's easy to extract from
here at the table we can use anything to
extract from here the right type of a
comparison that we would like to do the
other file the other file that we have
is the FASTA files and we'll talk a lot
more about fast and clustal files that
will actually represent multiple
sequence analysis but what I wanted to
do in the rest of this session is to
mention going back to what we did last
time how these faster files that
represent a consensus actually could be
analyzed in a very similar way and
provide us with a lot of detail about
the diverse population of viruses that
we actually have in a sample again I'm
sorry somebody's got their microphone on
so if you could please mute the
microphone in the meantime okay so as
remember last time we aligned reads onto
the reference genome so let's review
what are we actually seeing in this
visualization from last time we have the
reference genome right here in the
nucleotide level and we have three
different versions of how this
nucleotide sequence converts to codon
sequences or amino acid sequences so you
can see depending on the reading frame
three different options right so you can
see how the read sequences change in
specific positions and we call those
single nucleotide polymorphism snips or
variations single nucleotide variations
and we discussed about those having
different types right so here for
example you can see aji instead of an A
here you have a C instead of a tea etc
how do we actually look at those in fast
queue files so we have a short sequence
in every read right and together they
form coverage what we were just looking
at we can see three different types of
variants here right so for example here
we have a very strong difference in a
sense right because we have one two
three four five five different reads
that show us a difference from the
reference genome so we're pretty
confident about the substitution we call
it a substitution in this position we
will call a substitution in 1 2 1 3 from
T to a another option is if we have a
number of reads like we have two reads
right here that all show a gap and that
gives us high confidence that there's an
assertion or deletion of course two
reads is not a lot but just for
illustration purposes right and then
sometimes we will have conflicting
evidence so sometimes we might have
reads that actually show different
substitutions and then we actually don't
know
what is that substitution right and our
confidence is low so as a result we can
start looking at a number of things
inside a fast Q file
okay so we'll talk about this more next
time but one of the options that we can
do is look at different consensus
sequences present inside a fast Q file
so for example here we see how different
position mutating on the genome
represents different similar sequences
inside a fast Q file okay and the
question here what is the blue line
indicate so these are just reads right
so these are just reads and those reads
contain different types of mutations
right so then we can organize them by
similar mutations mutations in the same
positions or similar positions depending
on how we want to do that and say that
there's actually multiple potential
genomic sequences here that could be
assembled together and we call those
haplotypes or they're also sometimes
called viral quasi species we'll talk a
lot more about this in future sessions
but this is just for us to understand
the other option is we could just
generate consensus sequences from
multiple groups for example we had three
groups
right and I'll just show these two
pipelines we had three groups and we
want to understand what is a consensus
in each number of files in each group
right so for example what is the
consensus from the Gabon what is the
consensus from the Liberia what is the
consensus from the UK and we can put in
a lot of sequences in each group to
generate a consensus
another option is Shura right this
difference this is an assembly of
haplotypes right it will won't look at
different groups that we define it will
look for all the present haplotypes that
are likely to be present in the files
that we have okay questions now let's go
to question is it necessary to take
reference genome for making MSA entry
MSA does not require reference genome
MSA requires at least three sequences to
be present so if you have two that's not
called a multiple sequence alignment
multiple sequence alignment starts from
three and then it will just align them
to each other if you have a reference
and three or one of the three is a
reference you can then calculate
divergence from the reference for a tree
again you do not need to have a
reference but if you do have a reference
it is better to estimate the divergence
and that could be translated into the
evolutionary okay if you have any other
questions you can put them in here now
next time we will talk about a different
sequence analysis section
where we can combine these different
analyses together and what we'll do next
time is we'll actually apply this
analysis to the coronavirus data set
that we will together find on NCBI okay
so today we talked a little bit about
Ebola we'll do that same thing for kovat
19 and SARS coronavirus and beta
coronavirus and MERS so we'll talk about
that again and practice that a little
bit of a different way so that we could
really understand the logic okay
question here do the reference is always
the older well not necessarily right it
depends on the question that you have
and that's where I want to end this
session today is an assignment okay so
let's think about this we talked a
little bit about Ebola virus and we
talked a little bit about corona viruses
and there are many public domain
datasets available on both of these our
bricks so what we want to do for our
next session is to think of a question
that you have okay so that we can
organize those datasets in a meaningful
way so how do we do that I showed you
today
NCBI virus today and last time so you go
to NCBI virus and the first question
just so that you have an opportunity to
explore and see for yourself is to
understand what is the first available
sequence of an assembled genome for
Ebola virus from a human host
okay and Yala this could be a good
question for you how do we know how good
that assembly was and how was that
assembly done and how is the sequencing
done that will give you some sense of
whether you want to use that as a
reference for a novel outbreak okay the
second question that I have for you is
how many different hosts can you
identify with a full genome for all
types of corona viruses okay so we
talked about Ebola virus one of the
questions is what's the first one how do
we know what was assembled and who did
it right so let's just look into it and
find it the second one is corona viruses
you go into NCBI virus and identify how
many different hosts was that was
coronavirus sampled from okay
coronaviruses are abundant in cows and
in pets like dogs and cats and humans
and bats and apes so how many in total
different hosts can you find with a
known full genome okay make sure that
you're looking for full genomes and
let's compare what we found next time
and finally the real assignment is try
to find a bio project okay so this is a
little bit more than just looking on
NCBI a virus which is kind of easy to
use but now let's talk about bio project
with the sequence read archive samples
right so they will be fast queue files
but they will be compressed in SRA files
on Ebola or SARS one samples from human
hosts sequenced by aluminum ok you'll
find number of them sequenced by Oxford
nanopore you'll find some of them a
sequence by other sequencers we want to
focus on Illumina sequencers and we want
to find a number of different sequence
read archive samples as array samples
that are organized into a bio project
and so we'll have a chance to start
thinking about ok how do we find these
different sequences and then plan our
analysis in a short session so what is
the next session that we'll have our
next session on may 12th is going to be
dedicated to the preparation and running
of your pipeline so we will review
finding full genomes sequences and
preparing those FASTA files selecting
the right kinds of genomic sequences and
preparing a full pipeline of MSA and
phylogeny to answer a question that you
might have ok so that will be the focus
of our next session ok so that's what
I'll I hope that you all can start
working on for the next time if you have
some questions and you want to
follow a step-by-step tutorial first of
all you will be able to review this
recording and do the same steps the
second one is what I recommended last
time to really start from what we did
last time which is mapping reads onto
the reference genome and that is covered
in that sf9 project so beach if you
could post the link to the sf9 project
that has a very detailed step-by-step
explanation of what to do with the first
pipeline and I really was looking to see
that some of you would be able to go
through that project to really make sure
that you understand and that
step-by-step sequence
okay and analysis with free software so
I think you got what you were looking
for I showed you that analysis with NCBI
and with NCBI and those free tools of
course are publicly available in terms
of the tools that we're using here
they're also open source programs right
the only thing we want to avoid here is
you know dealing with technical issues
of installation and you know making sure
there works on your computer or on my
computer so that's one part of the story
that we want to avoid doing this program
as you can see we're moving pretty fast
and our goal is to get to a research
result and not you know figuring out how
to make your computer work with a
certain program which is typically a
very time-consuming task the other issue
here is that some of these files are
huge will be dealing here with files
that are you know many gigabytes in size
per sample and will take many samples
together will you know do something like
20 and 50 samples so these pipelines
will generate a lot of data and you know
I'm not sure that everybody I for
example don't have that much space on my
laptop so unfortunately that's just not
feasible
okay and for Claudia it is difficult to
see your screen and simultaneously open
the server will web for doing the
pipeline yes I'm sorry I understand that
and so that's why we'll spend next
session doing it very slowly and making
sure that all of you that are
participating can do the exact same
steps and I'm not rushing ahead and and
also you know if you view this recording
that's going to be posted very soon you
can pause and try to do those steps and
run the pipeline and we'll actually
comment on your pipeline if it wasn't
done the right way or there was some
issue you can see that we've already
been interacting with a number of users
that have been doing that right here on
the home screen so please go and review
here you know you can also link you can
actually go to some of these pipelines
that other people ran and and see what
is going on so you know try it and I
think everybody learns by trying and
again this recording thing I think will
be a good guide to just repeat the steps
but in the future right when you're
ready to kind of work on a project from
beginning to the end
we'll have the projects available for
Ebola and for coronavirus and for sf9
so take a look at those as well
okay so does anyone else have any more
questions about what we did here today
okay there are no more questions again
I'm looking forward to seeing you again
this is the next session preparing and
running your pipeline you know if you
had any questions between now and then
please post it on the forum on the forum
you'll have the recordings you will have
the sessions the the files that we use
today right so right here section data
files and presentations so you'll see
the presentation for today in a PDF
format you know if you have any
questions please put them here
recordings recorded right here and if
you have you know anything else you're
welcome to post it there take a look at
some of the courses okay if you want a
tutorial to follow step by step and run
some pipelines to understand how all of
this works you know at your own pace
here's multiple courses that you can
start looking at to understand if you
want some publicly available free tools
that you want to use here's a course
using our okay so you know we have a
collection of materials here that you
can access projects right if you want to
learn in in greater details